one here three and one-fifth plus 2 and
1/2 now the first method that I'm going
to show you is you're going to convert
these mixed numbers back into improper
fractions so the way you do that is you
take this number here the denominator
times the whole number plus the
numerator ok so this is 5 times 3 is 15
plus 1 is 16 so this is 16 fifths now if
you want to check your work you can
always take this and say well this is
like 16 divided by 5 five goes into 16
three whole times with one left over so
that's how you get the three in one
fifth back right ok same thing with this
one we're gonna do two times two is four
plus one is five okay and it's all
divided by that denominator two again
you can double check by converting it
back into a mixed number now in order to
add or subtract fractions you have to
have the same denominator so in this
case the lowest common denominator is
the smallest number that 5 goes into and
2 also will divide into so in this case
it's 10 so in order to get these
denominators to be 10 this one I'm gonna
have to multiply by 2 but whatever I do
to the denominator I want to do the same
thing to the numerator because 2 divided
by 2 is really like you know 1 + 1 times
anything is itself so if we say 2 times
16 is 32 2 times 5 is 10 we've converted
it okay 2 tenths same thing over here we
want this denominator to also be 10 so
we're going to multiply the bottom by 5
but whatever we do to the denominator we
want to do to the numerator because
again 5 divided by 5 is 1 1 times
anything is going to be itself so we're
not changing it we're just changing the
way that it looks
giving it a different denominator so 2
times 5 is 10
5 times 5 is 25 and so we've converted
it into tenths so all we have to do now
is combine these two fractions together
these are going to be all over 10 and 32
plus 25 is how much it's 57 so we have
57 tenths but now we want to convert it
back into a mixed number because the
numerator is larger than the denominator
that's an improper fraction 10 goes into
57 how many times well five whole times
right with 7 left over so this is going
to be five and seven tenths and that's
our answer okay let's go through another
example we're
you a subtraction problem this time but
this time what we're gonna do is we're
gonna subtract these in a vertical okay
method as opposed to this horizontal
method that we were using here
okay now the key thing here is we're
gonna look at these fractions and we're
gonna say hmm let's go ahead and get
common denominators what's the smallest
number that seven divides into and two
also divides into well that would be 14
right so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to multiply this denominator by
two and the numerator by 2 because
remember that's 1 so this is going to
give us 6 14 over here we want this
denominator to be 14 so we're gonna
multiply the bottom by 7 so that's 14 we
also have to multiply the numerator by 7
so that's 7 14 now you might notice that
we have an issue here because we're
subtracting we have 6 minus 7 how can
you take away 7 from 6 7 is larger than
6 right so what we have to do is we have
to borrow okay and so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna go over here to the
whole number we're gonna say okay whole
number I want to borrow 1 so I'm going
to change this to 3 okay because we're
borrowing one but we're actually doing
when we're borrowing one is we're
borrowing 1414 so you can see that we're
adding 1 here because we took away one
from the whole number but I made sure
that this had the same denominator as
this fraction ok so 14 divided by 14 is
1 now I can combine these together 6
plus 14 is 2014 right and now you can
see we can subtract 20 minus 7 is 13 14
and then we're gonna subtract the whole
numbers 3 minus 1 is 2 so we have 2 and
13 14 I kind of like this method better
just because what happens when you
convert them into improper fractions
sometimes you end up with you know some
pretty large numbers and then you have
to go and convert it back to a mixed
number so it seems like there's a lot of
like converting first you convert it to
an improper then you combine them then
you have to convert it back to a mixed
number whereas here we're you know this
is a little bit trickier but it's a
little bit quicker sometimes you have to
borrow from the whole number and you
want to make sure that you're borrowing
you know the same denominator so the
fortune over 14 if this was 10 I would
borrow you know 10 over 10 which is
still 1 so I hope you enjoyed this video
I hope that helped you to understand how
to work with them mixed numbers better
subscribe to the channel check out more
math tutoring videos on my youtube
channel Mario's maths
and I look forward to helping you in the
future videos I'll talk to you soon